[Music]
i think we'd both say that you know
those first couple of years on on
walking dead were some of the most
special times it was definitely for me
yeah special times of my life yeah um in
in in kind of every way
um it was just like
it was just kind of perfect um georgia
was perfect george was great george is
perfect and and uh
we're talking george has now passed some
laws that i don't know if i'd worked on
it well that's where i was going i guess
i guess like you know
it also was like the full experience
we're talking about last night of like
how wonderful this this art can be and
also how toxic this business can be i'm
just wondering if you can kind of like
take me through your
experience
going with frank garabant you know him
you know finding out that he was getting
fired in the middle of it you know what
that was sort of for you as much as
you're you're down with talking about it
yeah you know i'm down as well but like
you know what lessons did you learn from
that what what what did that
you know you you had been through it
babe yeah big show before like i hadn't
like that was like you know i was like
holy [ __ ] being on tv is amazing like
these people are [ __ ] great and like
yo this dude like i was in jail and now
i'm talking man i'm the biggest show in
the world and like holy [ __ ] this
dude saved my [ __ ] life and i'm
getting married and i'm about to have a
kid and why don't you fire in this dude
but wait he didn't do anything but like
now he's like what right and and i'm
just like wondering what that
rollercoaster was for for for you and
and i know he didn't get you know it's
not these same sort of things that we're
talking about now yeah no in a way he
did in a way he got
you know like it's um
it i don't know
yeah what was your take on that
you know it's
funny stephen young called me the night
before
and he was like we'd like we'd just
gotten back from comic-con i think
and he was like i heard that frank
darbox getting fired and i was like no
way
i was like no wait he just delivered amc
the biggest hit they've ever had like
that's crazy and he goes okay that's
yeah that's what i thought too but you
know
i'm kind of new to this and i was like
no man it's good go to bed
so literally the last time stephen
called me for advice
look there's so much i wasn't privy to
but to me it just felt like an
assassination
it just felt like
i mean the reasons that we were given
were like he's unexperienced as a
showrunner and he's unprepared and he
doesn't know what he's doing
i remember being like but this
[ __ ]
one month before we started shooting
season two
dropped six completed scripts in my lap
and said you can learn these lines
they're not going to change and they
were wonderful they were wonderful
and i like
this is probably a controversial thing
to say you cannot beat his writing you
can't
and
there are some really good people who've
been writing on that show since and i
got a lot of love and respect for them
nobody writes like frank darivan that's
a whole different level it's a whole
different level he has a level of
humanity
and a fearlessness with sentimentality
that is just
astonishing
and an economy of language do what i
mean like we've said this before but
like
that first scene i did with scott wilson
where i say you have no idea what you're
doing
you're you're completely in over your
head aren't you and he goes ma'am aren't
we all
that's the entire show it's a show yeah
i mean it it was extraordinary and so to
to have somebody say
he's not ready to be a showrunner
he's unprepared
there may have been legitimate grounds
for firing him if there were i never
heard them but that was a line of
[ __ ]
and
it pissed me off
and i remember walking up to kurt
kirkman and saying to him if you don't
think we know the difference between a
script written by frank darabon
and anybody else you're out of your mind
and i looked in his eyes and i thought
i'm going to get written off this show
shouldn't have said that i was too
pissed and but it was also that like
mama bearing me i was like we created
this beautiful thing frank was the one
who brought us in
like i'm gonna go to war for this guy
and you went to war for this guy and
jeff demand went to war for this guy and
we lost that more
in like
looking back on it
ah [ __ ] now i think this might be too
intensive thing to say it feels a little
bit like remember that guy that stood in
front of the tank in timmins square
dude i mean
just like i can stop this i'm under a
tank i'm under a tail i didn't stop this
i'm out of a job okay well
cool yeah um
but is there anything there i mean do
you hold your head high like do you do
do you feel
he's like i like like like i i don't
know man like i i
i don't know hindsight whatever i just
you know when i when i think about
when i think about what that guy did for
me what he did for my family what he did
for my life again we might not have been
privy
like for sure you know i i didn't play
ball like i was just like y'all are
rotten like that's [ __ ] up like he he
did not deserve to be like he made this
and like we like
you know i
unbelievable group of people working on
that show unbelievable like it was such
a huge success and such a
you know like i've done so many we've
done so many projects since then we know
so many other that one was unique and
special and hit the zeitgeist in such a
unique and and special way but like
i don't know for me i give him credit i
give him credit for you know ev every
single person that was there was there
because he put him there and he picked
him and the culture of that show and and
and the way that it it it's it's him and
and and getting rid of him when they got
rid of him and how they got rid of him
to me was just two weeks before he was
financially vested in the show like
that's something's wrong with him
yeah i mean look
you asked about loyalty earlier
like that was a lesson in loyalty
because i really truly thought
we can all rise up and stop this yeah i
remember remember it was the open letter
to variety and we were like in two camps
remember it was like one kid was like we
gotta keep working and then we're like
no we're walking off remember yeah i
mean the thought was if we all refuse to
come back to work until they bring him
back
it will at least bring enough attention
to the fact that this cast is furious
that maybe somebody
and then and
my my heart was a little bit broken when
there was almost no stomach for that
jody mean like there were you know you
and me and jeff like
it was kind of funny it was like you're
like charge and you turn around and
you're like there's all that no army
yeah oh my god it's me and a paper sword
um
george
i mean
you know and then yeah i mean but
look i'm i'm proud of it in retrospect
there were years afterwards that
financially were very scary
and like
those were years where i was like
what was the actual price of your
integrity yeah maybe you should have
shut the [ __ ] up because another two
years on that show with the raises they
got like
it's a different different deal that's
that's life-changing money you know and
again i'm a materialist the economics of
that decision i was like
you should remember you called me at one
point and you're like you are going to
war for a millionaire and you are not a
millionaire and i was like
i'm in it now you know like it's too
late but
um
i don't know and then there's also a
question of like if we'd shut the [ __ ]
up and stayed on the show
i don't know how happy i would have been
i don't know that i would have
you know and then you go on to do other
projects that really are deeply
meaningful to you and you go well i
couldn't have done that you know that
colony was a tremendous experience for
me and like couldn't have done it you
know i did a play right after it like
doing that play
meant the world to me
um
but yeah it kind of broke my heart
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody it's john
bam bam the dog
first on behalf of both of us and
everybody from the real ones team i just
want to sincerely thank you guys for for
tuning in the folks that i bring on the
show they're family to me and uh being
able to tell their stories and bringing
you into their world is something i'm
i'm just super proud of and uh again
grateful that you guys tune in we've
decided we want to take things just a
step further we're going to introduce a
patreon community and basically what
that means is if you become part of this
community look i already board bam bam
if you want to become a part of this
community you're going to be able to
hear episodes early and all that ad free
and all that good stuff but there's all
this behind the scenes footage all this
stuff that we've shot um that really
brings you into the folks that we've had
on the show really brings you into their
world you're going to be able to do live
chats with me and the folks that i bring
on the show to talk about their world
talk about the issues that they're
dealing with about their triumphs and
their tragedies just go to patreon slash
real ones on this website that you see
right there right on the screen that's
right in front of you this whole idea
was um something about building bridges
and and bringing people together and um
bringing folks that often don't get the
mic and giving the mic to them so the
fact that you guys tune in means the
world anyways again thank you uh be good
to each other out there rock and roll